[Music]
these elite-level racing wheels are made
of aluminum they're designed to generate
a smooth ride with optimum
responsiveness to the riders
acceleration workers load one extruded
tube at a time into a metalbender the
machine coils the tube around and around
forming four connected rims they mount
the coil tube onto a cutter with a
single downward slice it separates the
four rims first the rims need a bath in
a tank of acid the acid removes dust and
other contaminants and etches the
surface of the metal both of which help
ensure full adhesion of the
anti-corrosion coating they later apply
next a multi-phase heat treatment
process this restructures the aluminum
molecules making the metal harder and
stronger they join the two ends of the
rim by riveting on an aluminum connector
tab then they weld the joint to
reinforce it now for that anti-corrosion
coating the process is called
anodization in a tank
they plate the aluminum with the
protective chemical using an electrical
charge to draw the coating particles
onto the rim surface for this model the
anodized coating is black however there
are several color choices next a
computer-guided machine shaves off a
minut amount of anodized metal from
nearly 1/3 of the rim surface this
creates a smooth perfectly flat area for
the brake pads to grip
the next computer-guided machine drills
holes for the tiny aluminum nipples
which hold the aluminum spokes to the
rim now it's time to assemble the wheel
the first technician inserts a spoke
into each slide of a carbon fiber and
aluminum flange part of the hub at the
center of the wheel
once every spoke is in its respective
spoke seat as its called
he sandwiches them with a locking ring
now for the rim end of the spokes the
next technician places a small steel
plug inside a spoke nipple to make it
magnetic then she puts the nipple into
the rim and using a magnet draws it to a
spoke hole then through the hole toward
the inside of the wheel then she removes
the steel plug and inserts the free end
of a spoke into the nipple
[Music]
she repeats the procedure for each spoke
hole this is known as lacing the wheel
the next technician holds each spoke
steady while tightening its nipple with
a spoke wrench tightening the nipple
straightens the spoke the process of
perfectly aligning the wheel by
straightening every spoke is called
truing the wheel this gauge tells them
when the wheel is finally Trude for
quality control assurance this robotic
machine inspects each spoke and makes
any necessary tensioning adjustments
[Music]
depending on the model a high-end
bicycle wheel can have anywhere from ten
to forty six spokes different spokes
for different folks